Okay, guys, welcome back to the desk
again. So in the last video, we looked at
the mechanics of long idea processing.
Then Chris showed you how to process
sector and stock data and each of the
steps that you would go through to
identify positive and negative outliers.
And of course, potential. So the key word
there, guys, potential, long and short
outliers. So the key word there, guys,
potential, long and short outliers.
Now, long idea processing. What did we
actually do there? Well, we identified all
of the earnings growth profiles for
forward-looking earnings growth estimates,
expectations, as said by research analysts
in the market. So this is our earnings
growth one number and our earnings growth
two number. And we overlaid this with our
own requirements.
requirements to have the market on our
side. And we rank the earnings growth
profile estimates in preference for
growth. So we then, of course, take that
analysis and we apply it to a sector
whenever we are processing the data in a
sector. And Chris, of course, showed you
with the spreadsheet class, how to
download the data and
process it and process it with best
practices steps. In future, what you're
going to be doing is you're going to
become very, very familiar with all of
these earnings growth profiles. And
whenever you're processing, they're going
to always be in the back of your mind. So
you will naturally go through the
processes very, very quickly. And you'll
just get better and better at this.
At using the earnings growth profiles,
ranking them with preference and ranking
stocks with preference to their growth
when you're processing data. So
eventually, you'll end up doing this
without thinking about it too much. And it
becomes an autopilot situation. So you can
probably see where this is going now,
guys. Yes, conscious competence.
You're going to become competent at doing
this. Practice the processes over and over
and over
until you get good at it. And of course,
get used to it and you start doing it
naturally
without thinking about it too much. You
will start identifying opportunities
without thinking
about the earnings growth profiles too
much. You'll end up doing it naturally.
Now, we're going to
move on to mechanics now of short trade
idea processing. We're going to take the
same approach
by systematically going through earnings
growth profiles. But now we're looking at
them through a
short lens, which requires actually a very
different approach. In the video after
that,
what we're going to be looking at is
turnaround stories and value traps. And
we're going to learn
what to stay away from and what could be
opportunistic in that space. Then, in the
video after that,
we're going to be looking at the most
common mistakes in data mining and
processing. So, in the quant
phase, the mistakes that are commonly made
by retail traders in the quant phase, when
data mining and
processing during the bottom-up process.
This is actually going to help you a lot
in cementing the
processes that Chris taught you in the
previous video. So, let's shoot over to
the next video and I'll see you
back at the desk a bit later on.
Okay, so we are back at the screen. Video
number 26. We're going to continue now
with our trade idea
generation processes. And we're going to
be looking at the mechanics of short trade
ideas. We are again
going to be looking at percentage earnings
growth as a filtering metric within the
quantitative phase of the
overall bottom-up process. And here,
again, we have our quantitative and
qualitative dashboard as a
reference point as to the entire bottom-up
process. So, on the left-hand side, we're
going to be focusing again,
like in the last video on earnings growth,
except in the last video, we looked at
longs. In this video,
we're going to be looking at shorts. In
terms of the assumptions that we're going
to make in the
backdrop of establishing a portfolio bias,
well, in the previous video, we looked at
the quantitative
processes that pro-traders focus on at the
stock level when we're generating
potential long ideas.
And we assumed a bullish macroeconomic
view and a net long portfolio bias. So, we
assumed that you
recognized that the world is in a cyclical
upswing, that you're forecasting real GDP
expansion with Fed
target inflation intact and that your
portfolio bias is net long and you want to
be
aggressively long growth stocks in your
portfolio. In this video, we're going to
assume the same. However,
we're looking for shorts against longs
that are in that portfolio. And this is a
big lesson in itself.
Because at any one moment in time in the
future, even if you want to be
aggressively long growth names,
because you have a bullish predisposition,
you must always, always, always, always
still be seeking
out shorts and seeking out shorts that
will go down in value, even if the overall
stock market goes up.
And the opposite also holds true. Even if
you want to be aggressively short growth
names,
because you have a bearish predisposition,
you must always be seeking out longs,
and seeking out longs that will go up in
value, even if the overall stock market
ends up going down.
As traders and portfolio managers, we
can't just be naked long or short
everything and be 100%
100% in one direction. This is a surefire
way to blowing up your trading account.
Now, just as a reminder, we always want to
be going where the juice is. So remember,
we have our entire US stock market that
encompasses over 2200 stocks. Within the
stock market, we have our
industry sectors that have both cyclical
and defensive characteristics. And within
all of those sectors,
we have different types of stocks that
exhibit different types of
characteristics. We have growth
names, we have X growth names, and we have
value names. On the short side, we're
looking to be short,
X growth names, and potentially value
names or value traps. On the long side, in
the previous video,
of course, of course, of course, what do
we like? Well, we like what all money in
the stock market likes,
which is growth. So on the long side, we
seek to be long growth names. And on the
short side, we seek
to be short, X growth names, and
potentially what we call value traps. So
whether it's X growth or value trap,
and regardless of what sector the stock is
in, we always want to be optimizing in any
GDP growth
environment. So regardless of whether GDP
is growing or contracting, we want to be
short stocks that go
down in value. And we want to be short
stocks that underperform the sector and
the market in any GDP
environment. In this example, as mentioned
earlier, we are assuming a net long bias
in the portfolio,
emanating from an analysis of the macro
environment, where we believe that GDP
will expand and the stock
market will go up. So in the backdrop, we
have a net long portfolio bias, and we are
long growth names
in the portfolio. And we are seeking to
add shorts to that portfolio. Now, similar
to the previous video,
where we looked at those 10 earnings
growth profiles through the lens of long
ideas, so long idea
processing. In this video, we're going to
be looking at various earnings growth
profiles, but looking at them
through the lens of short idea processing.
And you can go into the download section,
and download the spreadsheet called
earnings growth profiles for shorts. And
you can see all of the
earnings growth profiles in that
spreadsheet that we're going to look at
here. But first, we need to talk
about some of the mechanics of potential
short trade ideas, some technical
situations, and some good habits.
So if you recall, from the previous video,
with our market cap filters, with short
ideas, you need to be
concentrating on the $20 billion plus
market cap space. From a short
perspective, from a revenue perspective,
perspective, from an earnings perspective,
a large cap or mega cap stock has more
potential to halve once it
goes X growth in a lower risk way than a
mid cap, or even a small cap stock or a
micro cap stock.
From a long perspective, a mid cap, say $5
billion market cap stock has more
potential to double and double
quickly than a mega cap $40 billion plus
market cap stock. So for long ideas, if
you recall, we need to
concentrate on the $3 billion to $10
billion market cap space. For shorts, we
need to concentrate on
large cap stocks that have $20 billion
plus market cap and mega cap stocks. For
mid caps, earnings growth is
generally greater than in large and mega
caps. For shorts, we are looking to get in
when growth is
slowing. So when a stock goes X growth. So
you have to use market cap as a filter, as
well as price earnings
ratio, earnings growth, and peg ratio. So
again, we are continuing here to build out
a portfolio where we're using essentially
volatility as a filter. So we have a
portfolio that presents us
both acceptable risk and good opportunity
to make money. And that, of course, as
you've seen before,
was covered in the IPLT video series. If
you haven't seen that, then I suggest you
do register and subscribe.
Because again, this is how everything fits
together. So from a portfolio volatility
perspective, the large
and mega cap space is ideal for us,
because initially, there is low volatility
for the 20 to 60 day time
horizon. But because their business
models. And they are vulnerable. When
something happens to these companies in
the negative, so when they go X growth,
that's when stocks fall and fall sharply
and volatility increases
significantly. So we as traders and
portfolio managers want to be capturing
those moves.
Additionally, when we are using market
capitalization as a quantitative filter
for our short idea processing,
when we are opening a trading account for
the first time, we want to get off to the
best possible start.
If you fill your portfolio with low market
cap shorts. So under $3 billion. And you
have lots of longs that are over,
say, $40 billion. So essentially, you are
short small caps, and long mega caps, you
are asking for trouble.
So in a GDP growth environment. So in a
GDP growth environment, for example, when
you have a portfolio
bias of net long, earnings growth is
larger and more sensitive to the business
cycle in, for example,
you are short mid caps versus large and
mega caps on average. So if you are
building portfolios,
where for example, you are short a mixture
of mid caps and small caps, and long a
whole bunch of mega caps,
and you're just starting out with a new
trading account, you are asking for
trouble because you
are short on average, higher earnings up
revenue growth versus long, lower earnings
up revenue growth on
average. So you are exposing yourself to
being short high earnings growth, and high
revenue growth, and
long low earnings growth, and low revenue
growth. You are also exposing yourself to
short high volatility,
and long low volatility. So this is
exactly the opposite of what we're trying
to achieve here,
as traders, when we're building long short
portfolios, you are asking for trouble.
And as time goes by,
you will blow up. Additionally, you're
exposing yourself to potential takeover
risk in your portfolio.
Because if you're short, a whole bunch of
low market cap stocks, and long a bunch of
high mega cap,
or large cap market caps, you're exposing
yourself to your low market cap stocks
being taken over.
They are much more likely to be taken over
mid caps than a large or mega cap.
Why? Because it's much easier for large
companies to get the financing to acquire
or take over,
for example, a mid cap company that
currently has a $3 billion market cap, and
they go and buy it for $4
billion or $5 billion, as in they pay a
premium for that stock, for that company.
It's much easier
to do that than to go out and raise the
financing for a $7,500 or $150 billion
market cap stock.
Additionally, large companies who are
looking to acquire other companies, they
are going to be more
attracted, like us, to growth. They are
not going to be attracted to X growth,
they're more likely to
be attracted to growth. So again, larger
companies will be more attracted to
smaller stocks,
rather than large or mega cap stocks or
companies simply because of their growth.
So it's easier to get the financing on a
much lower market cap because of the chip
size,
the size of the deal versus the size of
the deal of a large or mega cap. But also,
using that financing, companies would
rather acquire growth, they are more
attracted to growth,
like us. But also, just from a risk
perspective, from a trader's perspective,
when we're looking to
short stocks, let's have a look at a
takeover risk example. So let's say you
have a trading account of
$15,000 deposited on margin, and you have
the ability to leverage this four times.
So you can have a
$60,000 gross exposure portfolio. And
let's say in the portfolio, we choose to
have eight positions of
$7,500 notional exposure. And within those
eight, we have five longs and three
shorts,
but we choose to be net long, five large
and mega caps, and short three mid caps.
What actually happens if, for example, we
short $7,500 of a stock that has a market
cap of, say,
$3 billion. So it's defined as a mid cap,
market cap $3 billion. And the company is
taken over for,
say, $4.5 billion value. And the
announcement happens when the stock market
is closed. That's a 50%
premium to the market cap of yesterday.
The stock will simply go up 50% without
you being able to get
out. So you're going to be down $3,750 on
the trade. So on a total gross exposure
number of $60,000,
you are down $3,750, which is a 6.25% loss
on the gross exposure number. But on the
margin number of $15,000,
that is a 25% loss on your margin. This is
an irrecoverable position for an account
size that's this small.
It's going to take the risk that's this
small. It's going to take you at least 6
months, possibly even 12
months to make this money back in the
portfolio. This type of risk has to be
eliminated from your
portfolio immediately. So from the outset,
you must do, you have to place a market
cap filter on your short
ideas of $20 billion minimum. So only go
short, large and mega cap stocks to begin
with. When you're making
money six to 12 months down the line, only
then are you allowed to get clever, but
not in the beginning.
You've not earned the right yet to be
clever because you haven't made money.
Now coincidentally, this is why good
shorts are much harder to find than good
longs in a typical positive
GDP environment. Why? Because we have to
place a market cap filter of $20 billion
from the outset.
And just from a market cap perspective,
there's going to be less of these stocks
available in the market.
So the opportunity set is just smaller.
Additionally, within the opportunity set
of the $20 billion plus
market cap market cap stocks available at
any one time, we have to find fundamental
setups that exhibit
characteristics of good short ideas. So
not only is the opportunity set smaller
than our potential long
stock ideas, but within the opportunity
set, the amount of stocks that any one
time that exhibit fundamental
characteristics that enable us to be short
these stocks is much smaller. But
remember, we are looking
through the lens here of a positive GDP
environment. It's much harder to find good
shorts in that
environment in a slowdown in GDP. So when
GDP is slowing down and still positive,
but it's going lower. Or in a GDP
contracting environment, it's obviously
much easier to find shorts. But remember,
one thing is for certain. In any GDP
growth
environment, we can't simply be long 100%
in our portfolio or short 100% in our
portfolio. We have to
have either a net long or net short bias
or a neutral bias. In this example, when
we're looking at a typical
positive GDP environment, we still have to
have shorts in our portfolio. And we have
to do the work.
We have to generate as best we can, good
short ideas, even in the typical positive
GDP environment, and we must
have short positions in our portfolio.
Now, similar to when we were looking at
long ideas, we do have an ideal
ideal price earnings ratio set up for
short ideas. So our backdrop, what we want
to be having is something like this
for our PE profile for the stock relative
to the sector. So when you're filtering
for PE, you are looking for
for stocks that have a PE that's on a
discount to the sector in both period one
and in period two. But in
period two, the PE two, because we're
using current stock price divided by EPS,
we want the PE two to be
higher for the stock relative to its PE
one. Why? Because it means that EPS is
going lower in PE two
versus PE one. So we have lower EPS in PE
two versus PE one, and therefore negative
earnings growth.
Additionally, in this earnings growth
profile relative to the sector, you'll see
with the sector that the
PE for PE two is lower than PE one,
meaning that the sector is actually
exhibiting some sort of growth.
So that means that the average mean
earnings per share of the sector is
actually growing slightly from
period one to period two. Now it could be
even better, for example, if the EPS, the
mean EPS of the sector is
either the same or lower for the second
period versus the first period. But what
we've done here is
exhibited a case where it's just slightly
better. So the PE for period number two is
just slightly lower
than PE one. And that's kind of the
minimum ideal PE setup or PE situation for
the sector.
And then with the stock relative to that,
we want lower in both periods. And on top
of that, for the stock itself,
we want to see EPS lower in period two
versus period one. Now, just as a side
note, this is a situation where
EPS is positive in both periods for both
the stock and for the sector. So yes, we
will be looking at
earnings growth profiles of loss making
companies. But here we are looking at a
company that is in profit,
but their profit, their EPS is going
lower. And this is the ideal setup for us
in terms of EPS and price
earnings ratio for the stock versus the
sector. So in this situation, the stock is
potentially going X growth
in a sector that is growing slightly. So
this is the backdrop, the minimum backdrop
that we are looking for,
the ideal price earnings ratio set up when
we're processing for short trade ideas.
When we move on to earnings
growth, it becomes a slightly different
story into how we analyze earnings growth
through the filter of a
short lens when compared to when we do
this exercise, looking at earnings growth
profiles through a long lens.
So if you recall, when we looked at
sequentially positive earnings growth,
when we looked at long ideas as
the ideal situation, what did we have? We
had an earnings growth one percentage that
was higher than the sector,
higher than the mean average. And then in
EG2, we again had a stock earnings growth
number that was higher than the sector,
but in earnings growth two for the stock
itself, it was higher than in earnings
growth one. So we had a sequentially
positive earnings growth number for the
stock that is outperforming the sector,
that is outperforming the sector in both
periods. Now on paper, if we just reverse
that situation and we say, okay, we just
turn this upside down. And that's what
we're probably looking for for shorts.
What do we get? Well, we get in period
one, an earnings growth number that is
negative.
And worse than the earnings growth
percentage in period number one is
negative. And then in period number two,
it's negative again, and it's accelerating
to the downside. And again, it's
underperforming the sector. So the stock's
earnings growth is negative in both
periods.
And it's getting more negative in period
two versus period one. And in both
periods, it's underperforming the sector.
So on paper, what we're essentially
getting here is sequentially negative
below sector average earnings growth
momentum.
The problem is, the problem is, is that
with shorts, the earnings growth setup can
look attractive on paper.
But when you actually go into the market
and have a look at stock prices that
exhibit this scenario,
they're probably already going to be down
quite a lot. And yes, on the flip side,
when we're looking at long ideas that
exhibit sequentially positive above sector
average earnings growth momentum,
when we pull up the stock prices of those
companies, you're probably going to see
the companies up quite a lot.
But there is sometimes a difference in
that when we're looking at long ideas and
we're looking at valuations and earnings
growth and we're looking at price.
We saw in the previous video that for a
company to maintain its same PE ratio,
that the company in the positive would
have to be hitting its earnings growth
numbers,
its EPS, and the stock can continue
trading on the same PE, the same multiple
in the second period.
In that situation, the market continues to
reward the company with a premium to the
sector for delivering continuously on its
results, on its operations.
Yes, the stock in the journey with
sequentially positive above sector average
earnings growth momentum in that journey
from period one to period two, it can be
volatile.
But ultimately, if the company keeps
delivering, it's highly likely that money
is going to continuously reward the stock,
reward the company, and the company will
continuously trade on a premium to the
sector.
The differences with shorts when we're
looking at sequentially negative below
sector average earnings growth momentum,
it's likely that when we pull up this type
of earnings growth profile and then go and
look at the stock price,
the stock price, it's likely that the
stock price is going to be down
potentially quite a lot already.
And management is going to be doing things
in an attempt to stop the bleed, to stop
the earnings decline.
So there will be dynamic actions occurring
potentially in the market when we have a
static on paper earnings growth profile in
a stock that can already be down quite a
lot.
And if a stock is already down quite a lot
and it's exhibiting this type of earnings
growth profile, then stocks, when they get
to certain levels, can actually represent
to the market value.
And this type of value appraisal comes
from other players in the market,
investors who are looking at both the
balance sheet and the operation and coming
to the conclusion that at a certain level,
a stock is value.
So we have to look at sequentially
negative below sector average earnings
growth momentum in the same way that we
look at sequentially positive above sector
average earnings growth momentum.
This earnings growth set up, this earnings
growth profile on paper looks ideal, but
it is static and only on paper.
And things can change and things are
dynamic day to day in the market.
And we have to be very careful that we
don't, for example, short stocks that are
down a lot already and management are
doing things to turn around the company,
to turn around the fortunes of the company
and turn around earnings growth.
And on top of that, stocks are not at a
level where they represent value, where
investors are stepping in.
So sequentially negative below sector
average earnings growth momentum looks
ideal on paper, but it is hard to get in
at good levels when the market now knows
that this is the case.
It's likely that stock prices have already
moved down quite a lot.
So we have to be careful in our analysis
and treat it differently to sequentially
positive above sector average earnings
growth momentum.
Additionally, when we are identifying X
growth stocks, this does come with some
caveats.
When we are identifying X growth stocks,
it means that the stock is very clearly
beyond its growth phase.
When you look at further metrics like
revenue growth, for example, the stock may
be still in its growth phase.
And the management operating plan is to
choose to reinvest revenue and therefore
earnings into growing the top line.
So in this situation, the stock is a
revenue growth story.
So don't think because you see negative
earnings growth in an earnings growth
profile that a stock is automatically a
short.
It isn't.
You always have to do further work.
More work is required.
If this happens to you in your
identification phase in the quant for
short ideas.
If this happens to you, it's okay.
What you've done is, is you've just
identified a growth stock by going through
the process and you've learned more about
the stock and more about the sector.
This is why we have a filtering process.
We are in the process phase of identifying
potential shorts.
And sometimes when you're looking at
shorts and you're looking at earnings
growth profiles and looking at them
through a short lens,
you're going to bump into growth stocks
that exhibit negative earnings growth.
But they are still in their growth phase
because it's all part of their management
operating plan.
So don't think automatically that because
you see negative earnings growth, that a
stock is automatically a short.
It just isn't.
You need to do further work.
On top of this, you need to always be
aware about something that we call in the
processing phase, the law of small
numbers.
We're going to be covering this later when
we discuss processing mistakes in the
quant phase a bit later in the PTM video
series.
Now, similar to when we looked at long
idea processing in the quant phase and we
looked at earnings growth profiles there,
we're going to be looking at a number of
earnings growth profiles for short idea
processing.
And the first five we're going to look at
are all in a situation where they have
positive EPS in both periods.
Now, we've already seen our first one, the
ideal scenario on paper, which is the
sequentially negative below sector average
earnings growth momentum.
We're going to look at the others as well,
case two, three, four and five, and then
there'll be more cases later.
So case number two, we have negative
earnings growth and earnings growth that's
less negative in the second period.
And that's both below sector average.
We have flat earnings growth in the first
period, then going negative and both below
sector average for the third case.
For case number four, we have positive
earnings growth that's then going flat to
negative and below sector average.
And then case number five, we have
negative earnings growth in period one
that then goes to a flat or positive
position.
And again, both below sector average.
So let's have a look at these visually.
We've seen our first one, the sequentially
negative below sector average earnings
growth momentum.
On paper, the ideal setup.
In reality, it may not be.
The next one is probably the next best
thing that is actionable.
Negative earnings growth in period one and
negative earnings growth in period two and
both below the sector average.
And in this situation, we have a sector
average that has positive earnings growth.
And if you think about this one compared
to our sequentially negative earnings
growth, if you think about this one in
comparison,
if the sector is the same, but we have a
stock like this where we have negative
earnings growth and the earnings growth
situation is still negative in period two.
But the rate of the earnings growth
decline is slowing.
This could potentially provide a better
entry point or better short than case
number one.
Why would this be the case?
Well, it could be that the market is or
analysts in the market are hoping for some
sort of slowdown in the rate of earnings
growth decline.
And that may not materialize.
It may do.
It may not.
But we have to do more work.
The point is, is that this type of
earnings growth profile is not as bearish,
if you like, on paper as case number one
with the sequentially negative earnings
growth momentum.
So with a bit of hope priced into the
stock that the earnings growth decline
could be decreasing.
With a little bit of hope priced into the
stock, this could potentially provide us
with a better entry point, a more timely
short, because the situation could get
even worse than it is now.
But of course, as with anything else where
we're in the quant phase, more work has to
be done.
Moving on to case number three, we have a
situation here where the earnings growth
in period one is actually slightly
positive, but below sector average.
And then in period two, the earnings
growth goes very negative and is below
sector average.
And in this case, we need to be quite
careful.
We need to be careful here because we need
to analyze what is really going on at the
company.
There's obviously something that analysts
have flagged for period two that is going
to be very bearish for earnings growth.
Therefore, we need to work out whether
this is actually operational and it's a
material change in business conditions or
it's some sort of technical situation
through, for example, accounting.
So there could be, for example, a big
expected one off charge that's going to
occur in the following year that's going
to hit earnings.
And this is a very well flagged and
expected by the market.
So we have to understand that in those
situations, the market will look through
it or potentially look through it because
it's not a material change in business
conditions to the negative.
But when we pull up this type of earnings
growth profile, we obviously on paper know
for sure that earnings growth is getting
hit considerably in the following year.
Therefore, something bearish is happening
to earnings with the PE backdrop that
we've got.
If that's intact as well, it means the
market is punishing the stock.
It's trading on a discount to the sector.
And we have to do further investigation to
work out whether this is operational or
technical.
So in this case, we call this flat, then
going negative below sector average,
even if it's a tiny positive of say 1%
earnings growth, it's essentially flat.
Looking at our fourth case, we have in
earnings growth period one percentage,
we have positive earnings growth, which is
below sector average.
And then we have a situation in period two
where earnings growth percentage is going
to flat or negative and below sector
average again.
Case four, similar to case three is
showing us that the market is expecting
earnings growth to be positive in period
one or flat to positive in period one,
like in case number three.
But it's going flat to negative in period
two.
So the market is expecting an earnings
growth decline for the second period
relative to period one.
So again, similar to case number three, in
case number four, we must do further work
to figure out what this expectation in
period two is all about.
Why is there an earnings growth decline
expected by the market?
What is the reason behind it?
Is it genuinely operational where it's a
material slowdown in business conditions?
Or is it technical?
We have to go and figure that out and make
sure we understand what's behind the
earnings growth decline that's expected by
the market.
Now, what you will notice as we've gone
through case number one, two, three and
four is that you're looking at earnings
growth profiles that are potentially at
various stages of a company going X
growth.
Case number one.
Case number one, where we had sequentially
negative earnings growth momentum that is
below sector average in both periods.
That could be a situation where the stock
has gone X growth and it is late stage X
growth.
And when you've seen case number two,
three and four, these cases are
potentially cases that are earlier stages
of a company going X growth.
So it can be the situation that case
number four, for example, is at a much
earlier stage of going X growth versus,
for example, case number one or even case
number two.
So the stock prices may not have moved yet
to reflect the full discount that the
stock could potentially trade on in the
future.
So when we're looking at all of these
cases, we have to ask ourselves the
obvious questions.
Has the company actually gone X growth?
That is the most obvious question to ask.
And then to answer that question, we have
to look at the operation and find out if
there is a genuine material negative
change in business conditions.
And then to put it into context from a
short idea processing perspective, we have
to ask ourselves the next question, if it
is X growth, how far along are we in terms
of the stock being X growth?
And what is reflected in the share price,
how much has the stock gone down already
to reflect how far the stock or company is
down the line in terms of going X growth?
And are we early to the trade?
Are we early to the party or are we late
to the trade?
Are we late to the party?
Which brings us nicely onto our fifth
case, which is a situation where earnings
growth in this profile is negative in
period one and then positive in period
two, but below sector average in both
periods.
And this situation is like what we looked
at when we were looking at long idea
processing where there's a potential
turnaround story.
But there is a flip side to that coin
because a potential turnaround story can
also be a potential value trap.
So this situation here could happen in a
company going X growth in the early stage,
but it could also be a company that has
gone X growth and has been X growth for a
while.
And now the actions of management are
potentially turning around the company's
fortune, turning around earnings.
If you see an earnings growth profile like
this, where it could be early stage X
growth, then the EG2 number could be a
totally fictional hope number.
And the EG1 number is reality going
forward.
So EG2 could be downgraded.
So earnings in the second period could be
a hope number for analysts.
So that type of turnaround could just be
very low probability or fictional.
In the other case where a company has been
X growth already for a long time and is
far down the road of being X growth.
The stock could be down a lot.
It could be down 50, 60, 70, 80% already
underperforming massively for the last
one, two, three years.
And then all of a sudden we have some
expectation that there's going to be
earnings growth in the following year
after multiple quarters and a year or two
of earnings growth decline.
And in this situation, this could be a
scenario where we're looking at a value
play where other players in the market,
investors, are looking at a stock as a
value play.
That is different to when we're looking at
an early stage X growth stock.
However, the dynamic in this situation in
the way we view it.
So whether it's going X growth in the
early stage or it's been X growth for a
while, we view this in a similar way in
that we look at the earnings growth to
number.
So next year's number.
And we ask ourselves the question, is this
real?
Is it genuine?
Is it a real turnaround or is it a trap?
Now, as mentioned in the previous video,
when we looked at turnaround stories, the
earnings growth profile of a turnaround
story can be both opportunistic and
dangerous.
So they are opportunistic in that we are
looking at the market's expectation here
of a turnaround.
And from a long perspective, it can be
opportunistic in that the turnaround
actually happens.
They execute on it.
Looking at it through a short lens, it is
opportunistic in that the turnaround could
fail.
But it is also dangerous.
So when we look at it from a long
perspective, we are taking a position
potentially in a stock where the analyst
in the market, the market is expecting a
turnaround in earnings growth.
So we are going with the market, we are
agreeing with the market, but if the
turnaround doesn't happen, then of course,
the stock is probably going to go down a
lot and we're going to lose money.
Looking at it through a short lens.
Looking at it through a short lens, it is
dangerous because we are actually arguing
with the market here.
So we're saying that the market is wrong
to have the earnings growth number for
period number two and that we know better.
And of course, because we're going short,
where there's infinite amount of downside.
So especially in the case where a stock
has been X growth for a long time and then
the market is expecting a turnaround in
earnings growth and the stock is already
down a lot.
Going short, this type of earnings growth
profile in that type of dynamic can be
very dangerous.
So again, with all of these profiles that
we've looked at so far, we are assessing
from the earnings growth profile itself,
not only the direction of earnings growth,
but how far down the line.
The company is in terms of going X growth.
Is it early stage X growth or is it late
stage X growth or somewhere in between?
And also, obviously, we want to be finding
out the reasons why earnings growth is
forecasted to be negative by research
analysts, by the market.
We want to look at the market and
understand the context of the earnings
growth decline.
So the questions are always, has the
company actually gone X growth?
How far down the line is the company in
terms of going X growth?
How much is the stock price growth?
How much is the stock price down and how
much is reflected in the stock price move
and the bearishness already surrounding
earnings expectations?
What are the reasons for the earnings
decline or the expected earnings decline?
And is it going to continue?
Now, just as a side note, for clarity
purposes, when you're going through your
processing, you'll find that when we have
negative earnings growth profiles, that
your peg ratios are going to be negative.
So in the context of shorts, there is no
ideal peg ratio set up because peg will
just be negative in our ideal or close to
ideal earnings growth profiles.
Because when you're dividing a positive
price earnings ratio number by a negative
percentage number, you're going to get a
negative.
That's just going to be the case.
And the negative peg doesn't tell us
anything about valuation and what the
market thinks of the stock relative to
other companies.
So in these situations, when you're
looking at negative earnings growth
profiles from a short processing
perspective, you can overlook negative
peg.
As in the ones that have negative earnings
growth.
So they would be our cases, case number
one, two and five.
But our cases number three and four would
have slightly different peg setups.
So we would have a positive peg ratio in a
period number one because we have in
period number one positive EPS.
We have positive PE and a positive
earnings growth number.
So we have a positive divided by a
positive, which gives us a positive peg in
year one.
So if we have negative peg like our cases
one, two and five in a positive EPS
environment, it's because we have negative
earnings growth.
Which from a traders and portfolio
managers perspective, when we see those
negative pegs, it just gives us
confirmation of the numbers.
Negative peg has a weak interpretation for
us.
So we take note of the negative peg.
However, we do not put too much weight on
the interpretation for it.
In our cases number three and four, if we
have a positive peg in a positive EPS
environment, it's because we have in the
period a positive earnings growth.
If we then see that peg go negative in the
next period, it's because we know that
earnings growth is going from positive to
negative.
So from a short perspective, from a short
trade ideas processing perspective, this
visually is confirmation for us that we
are getting negative earnings growth in
the next period.
It's close to ideal or it's the next best
thing.
Now we have several other cases of
earnings growth profiles that we can look
at for short idea processing, looking at
them through a short lens.
Up next is case number six and case number
seven.
So case number six, this is where EPS is
positive again, but earnings growth is
positive and then positive again.
Period one, then period two, but it's
lower than the sector in both periods.
This is not ideal.
This is more like a hedge and we are not
hedgers.
We are traders.
We want better than this.
Case number seven, anything that is
equivalent to the sector or higher.
So it's just not worth looking at.
So looking at positive, then positive
earnings growth period one and period two,
but below sector average, what we've
actually got here is for the stock itself
earnings growth momentum.
So we have sequentially positive earnings
growth momentum for the stock, but it's
below sector average for both periods.
We could have just as easily put on the
screen in period two, a slightly better
positive earnings growth number.
We could have put on the screen a flat
earnings growth number or slightly worse.
That would be pretty similar because it's
positive and positive looking through a
short lens.
In all of those scenarios, this would
probably not qualify as good as the
situations that we've looked at so far.
Definitely not for the sequentially
positive earnings growth, even though it's
below sector average.
This for an investor would potentially
provide a hedge to a long idea in the same
sector.
But again, we are not investors.
We are not into hedging.
We are looking for the juice.
We want stocks that are going to get
clobbered.
We want stocks that are going to go down.
We want shorts that are going to go down a
lot and longs that are going to go up a
lot.
We want to be going where the juice is.
For case number seven, it's a pretty
similar situation.
In both periods, we are exhibiting
earnings growth for the stock that is at
or very close to being equivalent to the
sector earnings growth in both periods.
Again, this is not ideal for us when we're
looking through a short lens.
We're not into sector performance.
We want to do better than this.
We want to be short stocks that are
potentially going to really underperform
the sector and the market in any GDP
environment.
And not just underperform, but go down a
lot.
Now, moving on to our next three and final
three, actually, earnings growth profiles
when we're short idea processing.
Now, all of these companies, at least in
the first period, have negative EPS.
So they are loss making companies.
And then also in the first period, they
have negative earnings growth.
But what's different about these cases is
what happens in the second period.
So let's take, for example, case number
eight, where we have a loss making
company.
So negative EPS, at least in the first
period.
And they get negative earnings growth in
period one.
And the earnings growth is below sector
average.
Then in the second period, they have
positive earnings growth.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's positive EPS.
It can also be negative EPS.
But it's just less negative.
But the positive earnings growth number is
above sector average.
We would again define this type of
earnings growth profile as a turnaround or
value trap, potentially.
So this, again, is both opportunistic and
dangerous.
With case number nine, we again, in period
number one, have a loss making operation.
So we have negative EPS.
We have negative earnings growth as well
in period one.
And it's below sector average.
In period two, we also have negative
earnings growth, but that is at or below
the sector average.
So what's happening here is that in period
two, the company is losing slightly more
money than it did in period one.
But the earnings growth decline is lower.
So this is similar to our case number two.
Again, this is a turnaround or value trap
situation, opportunistic and dangerous.
And finally, with our case number 10, our
final case, we have in period one, a loss
making operation, negative EPS, with
negative earnings growth, that's below
sector average, moving to a scenario in
period two, where we have EPS growth,
that's even more negative than period one.
And it's below the sector average.
So this is like our case number one, the
sequentially negative below sector average
earnings growth momentum.
But the company is already in a loss
making situation.
So the question is here is whether we're
trying to be a hero trader and trade the
stock to zero, because it's highly likely
in this situation, as long as this is not
a revenue growth story, and it's part of
the management operating plan to have
negative earnings growth in order to grow
the top line.
So on the condition that this is genuinely
a stock that has gone X growth in a
situation like this, where the company is
loss making, it's highly likely that it's
way down the line of going X growth.
So the question is, is how far the stock
has already moved already, and if it's
down a lot already, say 50%, 60%, 70%,
80%, 90%, if it's down a lot already, are
we trying to be the hero trader here and
trade this stock to zero?
Are we late to the party?
Or are we early to the party?
In this situation, it's highly likely that
we're late to the party.
So let's have a look at these visually to
understand them a little bit better.
Here we have case number eight, where we
have negative earnings growth from a loss
making operation in period one, that's
below sector average, and then we have
positive earnings growth that's above
sector average in the second period.
And in the second period, remember, this
can also be negative EPS as well as
positive EPS.
So we could have a situation here where a
company, for example, is going from
negative 60 cents to negative 1 cent in
their earnings in their EPS.
So essentially, they've recovered 100% of
their losses.
So they have 100% earnings growth in the
second period relative to earnings growth
in the first period.
Or they could be going from negative 60
cents to positive 1 cent.
So again, around 100% earnings growth.
It's essentially the same as losing 1
cent.
So again, as long as this is defined as a
genuine X growth scenario, we can look at
this as a potential turnaround or value
trap.
So again, we are always assessing the
context as to whether it's a genuinely X
growth story, how far down the line we are
in terms of the company being X growth,
the reasons for it, how much the stock has
moved, and in this particular situation,
whether a turnaround is actually genuine
or not.
Next up is our case number 9, where we
have, again, a loss-making operation in
period 1, where we have negative EPS.
And we have negative earnings growth
that's below sector average in period 1.
And in period 2, we have negative earnings
growth in period 2, that's either at or
below the sector average.
And if you recall, this earnings growth
profile is very similar to our case number
2, except this situation is the company is
actually loss-making instead of
profit-making.
So we are looking at it through the lens
here, the same earnings growth profile.
We are looking at it through the lens of a
loss-making operation rather than a
profit-making operation, because in the
first period, we've assumed that the
company has negative EPS.
So again, this is a turnaround or value
trap story, and we have to be very
careful.
We have to put everything into context as
to whether the company is really an X
growth, a genuine X growth situation.
If it is, how far down the line they are,
how much has the stock price moved, why is
the company X growth, and also whether the
turnaround or value trap exists.
Next up is our final case, case number 10,
where we have negative EPS in period 1
with negative earnings growth below the
sector average.
And then in period 2, we have more
negative EPS and more negative earnings
growth.
That's again below the sector average.
So remember, this is like our case number
1, where we have sequentially negative
below sector average earnings growth
momentum.
So on paper, it can look good, but in
reality, it can be bad.
Because again, it's all dependent on
whether it's genuinely an X growth story,
how far down the line they are in terms of
going X growth,
how much the stock price has moved, the
reasons, whether we're late to the party
or not.
And of course, if there's better earnings
growth profiles out there and better, more
well-timed shorts.
So remember, in this situation, yes, we
have the sequentially negative earnings
growth momentum that's below sector
average, similar to case number 1.
Case number 1.
But here, we are a loss making operation.
Case number 1 was a profit making
operation.
So it's highly likely that if all of these
X growth factors are in place, that this
scenario, we are way further down the line
of this company being X growth than even
case number 1.
So this covers our 10 earnings growth
profile cases when we are processing in
the quant phase for short ideas and
looking at these earnings growth profiles
through the lens of short ideas.
And as mentioned, we have to take a
different approach versus when we're
looking at long ideas and going through
the processes there in the quantitative
phase and looking at earnings growth
profiles through the lens of long ideas.
So for earnings growth profiles, when
we're short idea processing, we've got to
think of it in terms of EPS and earnings
growth in four ways.
We have positive EPS with negative
earnings growth.
We have positive EPS with positive
We have characteristics where we have
negative EPS, so loss making operations
with negative earnings growth.
And we have loss making operations, so
negative EPS, but have also positive
earnings growth.
Now, intuitively, you would think that
just finding companies that lose money
would make great shorts.
So loss making companies automatically
becoming great stocks to short, but that
is not necessarily the case here.
You have to be very careful because stocks
may have already traveled and you could be
shorting something that's already down a
lot.
So shorting it in a hole.
So it could already be down 50, 60, 70,
80, 90%.
And you could be very late to the party
and get caught out being short.
Remember, markets are forward-looking
animals.
We are forward-looking and we're not ever
backwards-looking in our analysis as
traders.
A stock, for example, that was a $50
billion company three years ago, that is
down, say, 80%, is now a $10 billion
market cap company.
On that journey from $50 billion to $10
billion, they may have had positive EPS,
but had gone X growth and fallen into
negative EPS, so fallen into losses.
And this is partly why we have a market
cap filter on shorts.
We want to be looking to go short stocks
that are going on that journey, and we
don't have to capture all of the journey.
In fact, for both longs and shorts, we
always want to avoid trying to pick
bottoms and tops.
So in the classic long setup where we have
sequentially positive earnings growth
momentum, we are playing the earnings
growth and we are playing that momentum.
But even if we are wrong, our gap risk to
the downside on a long position is 100%.
We can only lose 100% of our money on a
long stock position.
In the classic short setup that we looked
at where we have sequentially negative
earnings growth momentum, we are
potentially playing the earnings growth
decline.
But in that scenario, our gap risk is
actually infinity.
On a short stock position, we can lose an
unlimited amount of money.
And for both long and short positions,
with long positions, the gap risk is 100%
whether we buy something that's up
significantly over the last one, two,
three years, or whether we buy something
that is down significantly over the last
one, two, three years.
With shorts, the downside is infinity
whether we short something that's up a
huge amount over the last one, two, three
years, or whether we short something
that's down a lot over the last one, two,
three years.
It simply doesn't matter.
So this is why we have to treat shorts and
earnings growth profiles differently than
how we treat long earnings growth
profiles.
Because in shorts, we can get caught out
and potentially lose a lot of money very
quickly.
So this is partly why we have a market cap
filter on shorts.
We are putting a market cap filter on to
lower the probability that we're going to
get caught out and lose a lot of money on
our shorts.
For example, eliminating the takeover risk
element in the short.
And what we're looking to do is go short X
growth names that are either large cap or
mega cap in characteristic.
So we're looking to short X growth names
that are either mega cap and they're going
to in the future become large cap.
Or we're attempting to short X growth
names that are large cap and at some point
in the future, they're going to be mid
caps.
What we're also trying to avoid with
shorts is to short or attempt to short
stocks at the top.
So we're not trying to pick the top here.
What we're trying to do is look for
evidence of stocks going X growth and with
attempting to capture a part of that
journey.
So for example, on the journey for a $50
billion stock becoming a $10 billion
stock, maybe we can capture half of that
move.
So when we look at earnings growth
profiles that are negative and also when
we see turnaround stories or potential
turnaround stories or value drops,
when we look at them through a short idea
processing, short idea lens, we have to be
very careful.
So for example, when we see an earnings
growth profile that has sequentially
negative earnings growth momentum,
whether that's a loss making company or
even a profit making company, we could be
too late to the trade.
Additionally, if we see a turnaround
stories or potential turnaround stories,
which are also potential value traps.
Again, whether it's negative EPS or
positive EPS, we could be in a situation
here where we are late to the party.
So we have to be very careful and take a
different approach versus long idea
generation.
Now, recall the ideal price earnings ratio
set up where EPS is positive.
It has to be, otherwise PE would be
negative due to a negative EPS.
So in our ideal PE backdrop, our ideal PE
setup, we have a positive PE ratio that's
lower than the sector average.
And then in period two, we have a slightly
higher PE, but again, it's lower than the
sector average.
What's not ideal from a PE setup
perspective for the PE backdrop is for
example, if we have negative EPS in both
periods.
Why?
Because we may have gone already on the X
growth journey and the stock may already
be down a lot.
And we are now in a loss making period
coming from a profit making period.
So if the company is loss making and we
have negative PE in period one and
negative PE in period two, we got to be
very careful.
We have to look at the context here and
figure out where the company has come from
previously and where it is now in
comparison and whether it's already got on
its X growth phase, whether it's very late
in the stages of the company going X
growth.
Because this situation here, where we have
negative PE in period one, where the
company is loss making.
And then in period two, the PE is still
negative, but it's higher.
Now, we could be walking into a short trap
here.
We could be walking into a turnaround
story.
But of course, again, it could also be a
value trap where the turnaround story
doesn't materialize.
We still have to do further work to work
it out, but it's not ideal.
Now, one of the best ways to think of how
we look at earnings growth profiles and
how we look at shorts and earnings growth
profiles is to think of it in terms of a
roadmap.
And where on the journey do we think we're
actually capturing the X growth company?
So we tend to think of things in terms of
short waves.
So when we have forward looking
fundamentals, so expectations are shifting
from positive to negative.
So we have an X growth story.
Stocks tend to travel lower over a period
of time in several waves.
So here we have characterized five phases
of an X growth story.
So let's start with phase one, P1.
This usually begins with some sort of
capacity or market size issue.
So the company has reached a growth
capacity and the stock starts to put in
several tops.
This period of time is usually associated
with a lot of bullish hubris in the market
that the company can always continue
growing at the same pace forever.
On top of that, the company itself is
usually reluctant to issue any bearish
estimates and always attempts to calm the
market several times by just reiterating
guidance over and over.
The next phase of an X growth story is
phase two, where expectations actually do
shift lower.
And they are now those expectations being
started to believed by the market.
This period is usually associated with a
lot of profit taking from long term
investors.
So long term bulls on the stock or cutting
from more short term players in the market
from hyperbolic bulls that bought at or
near the top.
At this stage, usually what happens is the
company actually does issue materially
lower guidance, but they do it
reluctantly.
But what happens is, is by the time the
company has actually issued that
materially lower guidance, the stock has
already moved down before they do.
And this tends to be because analysts have
already moved their expectations in the
market.
And the company lowers their guidance
later because they are reluctant to do it,
but they end up having to admit it.
Now, this brings us on to phase three,
where in the market, a new normal growth
rate expectation is set by the company and
equity research analysts.
And this flushes out more of the stale
long investors.
And what tends to happen with these
situations is that it's accompanied by the
company now actively seeking a new
management operating plan, an MOP, and
starts to talk and verbalize about a
turnaround.
And then new investors begin to enter the
market, usually dollar cost averaging on
the way down for the turnaround story that
they believe in, that the company is now
pushing in the market.
Stale bulls and investors who don't
believe the turnaround story sell to those
that do.
But in phase three, what usually happens
is the stock takes another leg lower.
And now we move on to phase four of when
companies go X growth, where the stock is
now down materially from its highs.
So we're talking 50, 60, 70, 80, even 90%
plus.
And at this stage, it's a totally
different company to the one prior to and
in phase one.
And what tends to happen at this stage is
the new company management operating plan
is rolled out and the market is starting
to see evidence that the rate of decrease
in fundamentals is slowing down.
So the market is starting to see evidence
that the bleed has stopped or it's close
to stopping.
And the question always is here, will they
pull it off?
Will they pull off the turnaround?
But from a trader's perspective, we look
at it from the perspective of who really
cares?
Because we want to be shorting stocks way
before phase four happens.
So we want to be shorting stocks in phase
two and phase three.
In phase one, we're not looking to pick
the top.
In phase four, we are not looking to short
stocks in a hole.
In phase four, stocks can trade sideways
and occasionally have very ugly rallies,
very ugly short squeezes.
And there's a lot of volatility around,
but ultimately stocks will probably go
sideways.
But we don't want to be caught up in that
as traders.
And then what happens, we have phase five.
And in phase five, either the company
management pulls off a turnaround.
So they manage to turn the company around
or they don't.
But at this stage, as traders, we don't
care.
We are traders, not investors.
What we are looking to do is catch phase
two and phase three and then move on to
the next one.
So with these short waves, of course,
every situation is different and should be
judged on its own merits.
This is just a rough guide or template as
to when a company goes X growth and
handles it badly.
So they go all the way from phase one to
phase five.
On the journey through phase one, phase
two, phase three,
a lot of company managements could
potentially see the issue coming and
simply pivot in phase one or phase two,
or even in phase three.
But don't worry.
This is why we have diversification in our
portfolio.
Now, bigger companies tend to find it hard
to turn around X growth situations
quickly.
A speedboat, so a smaller company can zip
around the ocean quickly.
The company, a smaller company can tweak
their management operating plan
to suit the times and implement across the
board.
And lines of communication in smaller
companies are quicker and they can get to
market a lot quicker.
With larger companies, they are like oil
tankers.
They move slowly around the ocean and
innovation tends to be slower.
And management operating plans can't
change and they can't go to market
immediately.
And lines of communication in larger
companies tend to be very slow and
cumbersome.
So when you think of the market cap space
of mid caps and large caps and even mega
caps, look at it like this.
Mid caps, the three to $10 billion market
cap space.
Large caps, the $10 to $40 billion market
And of course, on top of that, we have
mega caps, $40 billion plus.
So think of it in this way.
If you go long a $7.5 billion market cap,
mid cap company and short, say a $30
billion market cap, large cap company.
If the mid cap doubles and the large cap
halves in one year, they meet in the
middle at $15 billion market cap.
Now for the record, for long ideas, we
don't have a similar wave template for
classic sequential earnings growth long
profiles.
Because in the way they journey, it can be
very varied.
So how the stock travels to the upside can
be extremely different from one case to
another.
With short ideas, when companies go X
growth, the wave template exhibits a very
typical average profile of how a stock
journeys throughout the waves.
So let's have a look at some real examples
here.
So we can see on the screen here, Under
Armour, which is an apparel brand.
And this is Under Armour going X growth
and traveling from being a $25 billion
stock at $50 a share to becoming a $5
billion stock at $10 a share.
So what you can see on the screen here is
the various phases like in our short wave
template.
So we have phase one, which is where the
company puts in a top in 2015, falls and
has its first move down and then trades
sideways between $40 and the high $40.
You can see where the red arrow is
pointing at the first red arrow.
This is where phase one begins.
And then the stock drops from mid-40s into
the high 30s and treads water in the high
30s and low 40s.
So this is the stage where the company is
threatening to go X growth.
But at the time, of course, management
will have been reiterating guidance and
defending the stock, defending the
company.
But the growth trajectory of revenue and
earnings that they experienced say from
2012 to 2015 and the beginning of 2016 was
now in question.
So the company was potentially going X
growth.
And then we have the phase two period
where it's actually confirmed that the
company is going X growth.
And then we have the phase three phase
where a new normalised growth rate, which
is slower than the old growth rates, is
set as an expectation by the company and
the market.
And we end up in the mid-20s and even the
low 20s and chopping sideways.
And then we move into phase four, which is
when the company starts to bottom.
The stock starts to bottom in the phase
four period.
And this is where the turnaround story
begins or whether it's a value trap.
The new management operating plan is
rolled out in an attempt to turn around
the company.
And you can see phase four lasts from
somewhere in the region of towards the end
of 2017 all the way up to 2020.
And this is quite typical of phase four
scenarios.
They can occur for a long time and we can
get a lot of volatility during the phase
four period because it does take a long
time for management operating plans to be
implemented and for them to actually start
working.
So from a trader's perspective, we
obviously want to avoid shorting stocks in
a whole.
So shorting stocks in phase four and phase
five at or near the bottom.
Obviously, we don't know that at the time,
but we can understand the characteristics
of X growth stocks and where they are in
their journey.
And we will be better off looking for
other situations.
On top of that, we don't want to be trying
to pick the top.
So we don't necessarily want to be in
phase one, phase four or phase five.
We want to be capturing the journey when
we get confirmation that the X growth is
occurring.
And we're moving to a lower growth rate
very rapidly.
If you look at the period here from mid to
late 2016, when we have a break to the
downside, that's phase two.
And then the break to the downside again
in early 2017.
That's phase three.
So we want to capture those moves.
As traders and portfolio managers, we
would have wanted to have captured the
move in Under Armour from around high 30s
dollars down to low 20s dollars.
But of course, we're not going to capture
all of the move.
If we can capture half of it, two thirds
of it, three quarters of it, we're doing
very well.
Another example that demonstrates the
progression of our shortwave template is a
company called Teneco, T-E-N, which moved
on the journey from being a $4 billion
market cap stock at $70, becoming a $250
million stock at $3 a share.
And Teneco is in the automotive equipment
market.
So we can clearly see a phase one period
from the end of 2016 to around the end of
the first quarter of 2018.
And then phase one, this is an area where
we're probably not shorting the stock, but
we're starting to see that a company could
be going X growth.
And then when we actually see it break to
the downside, this is where we want to be
playing it and we get confirmation that
the stock is now X growth.
So we would have liked to have been
shorting this stock around June to
September 2018 to enable us to capture the
phase two move and the phase three move
down in the stock.
We can also see after we have the phase
three move down, we get the phase four
period beginning.
So after the phase three move down, the
phase four period begins in the time
horizon between June and September 2019.
And you can see that the phase four period
lasts a very long time, all the way up to
the end of the chart, which is in around
April 2021.
So almost two years the phase four period
happened before the phase five period
occurs.
And this is where either the turnaround
happens or not.
And if you want to go and have a look at
this stock, go away and have a look at it.
And you'll see that the stock rallies
actually quite significantly from the $10
level up to above the $20 level in a very
short space of time.
But obviously, that's not a full
turnaround.
We're still in the phase five period.
But the phase five period began in April
2021.
But these are two good examples, Under
Armour and Tenneco, because they're in two
different market cap spaces.
So Under Armour started off as a $25
billion stock and went from being a large
cap to a mid cap.
And Tenneco went from being a mid cap, a
$4 billion stock to being a micro cap.
So these are good examples to use because
the way we look at things as traders and
portfolio managers,
with our market cap limits on our shorts,
we would much rather be shorting Under
Armour rather than Tenneco.
Even though Tenneco may have exhibited X
growth characteristics,
we would much rather be short Under Armour
even if Tenneco is available.
And you can also imagine in both
scenarios, when Under Armour had already
dropped significantly,
and we were in phase four, and Tenneco had
already dropped significantly,
and we're in phase four or even phase five
for both stocks.
We don't want to short either of them.
We want to be staying away from those
types of shorts.
So we'd much rather filter for market cap
and be shorter stock like Under Armour in
that situation
than be short in a stock like Tenneco
simply because of the market cap and the
gap risk.
But neither of them.
We want to be involved at phase four and
phase five or even in phase one.
We want to be capturing phase two and
phase three in stocks like Under Armour.
Let's have a look at a mega cap stock that
is actually in phase one and has a big
question mark over it.
We looked at this stock, Shopify, earlier
in the video series, and we realized that
revenue growth was slowing down post-2020,
below 2019 and previous year levels.
And if we take a snapshot of Shopify in
April 2021, we can see the stock price is
$1,145.46.
It has a market cap of $165 billion.
So it's already put in a top at this
stage, just above $1,400.
So the question is, is if we're seeing a
fundamental slowdown of the top line and
potentially a fundamental slowdown in
other parts of the business relative to
previous years,
are we in phase one and is it going to get
worse?
So the $1,400 and the $165 billion stock
becomes what?
Well, at this moment in time, we just
don't know.
And this is a great example as to why as
traders and portfolio managers, we don't
try to pick the top.
We don't try to go short stocks that
haven't become confirmed X growth names
yet.
If we had a fundamentally bearish tailwind
in Shopify, where we're seeing evidence of
top line growth falling quite
aggressively,
and earnings estimates from analysts being
cut and the stock starts to break to the
downside, perhaps below the 1,000 level.
This is where we want to start getting
short to take advantage of the phase two
and the phase three move, if that
potentially plays out.
So Under Armour and Teneco are good
examples of why we try to stay away from
phase four and phase five situations,
because they become turnaround stories or
value traps and have a lot of volatility
around that price for a long time.
And we can just get caught out being
short.
Also with Under Armour and Teneco, they do
display that at the moment in time of
phase one,
we're probably not confirmed yet that the
stock is going X growth.
And we need the stock to confirm that and
for it to break to the downside so we can
take advantage of phase two and phase
three.
And Shopify is the perfect example of why
we wouldn't short something in phase one,
because it's too early.
It's too early.
It's too early yet to know whether the
company, whether the stock has gone X
growth.
Now, what we've talked about so far in
this video on short idea processing.
It's all been about fundamental earnings
growth.
But when we're shorting stocks, there are
technical factors that we have to take
into consideration as well.
And something we always have to consider,
even with long ideas as well, but
especially with short ideas.
We need to consider short interest in the
stock.
And a really good resource for checking
short interest as a retail trader is a
website called shortsqueeze.com.
You should register there.
It's well worth the small annual fee to
become a member of that website because
you'll be able to check short interest in
any stocks that you have ideas in.
So short interest is calculated as a short
interest percentage.
So that's the amount of shares that have
been sold short in the market divided by
the amount of shares in issue.
So the float of the company.
And what this does is give us a sentiment
gauge on how bearish the market is on the
stock, but a much more useful measure,
even though we do need to know what short
interest is all the time and be aware of
it.
A more useful measure is actually the days
to cover ratio.
This is a liquidity measure.
So the liquidity measure of days to cover
ratio is the amount of shares that have
been sold short in the market divided by
the average daily volume of the stock over
the last 30 days.
And what this does is tell us that if
everyone in the market who is currently
short the stock went into the market to
buy all of their shares back, how many
days would it take them to actually buy
all of their stock back?
This is why it's a liquidity measure.
So, yes, we absolutely have to be aware of
what the short interest percentage is, as
in how many shares have been sold short as
a percentage of the amount of shares in
issue, the float.
That can be very, very important.
But this is more of a sentiment indicator.
But what we also have to be aware of is
the liquidity measure of days to cover.
So the days to cover ratio.
This is more important because it really
gives us an understanding of the actual
liquidity of the short that's out there
relative to the amount of volume that is
trading in the stock.
So short interest when we're using it in
conjunction with the days to cover ratio
is both a sentiment and liquidity measure.
You should use this as part of your
technical analysis for both short and long
ideas.
So imagine if we have a high days to cover
ratio.
This basically means that there's a big
risk of a very large short squeeze that
could occur in the stock when all the
shorts have to buy or cover their shorts.
So when they step into the market and buy
all of their shares back.
Now, both a high short interest percentage
and a high days to cover ratio could also
mean that we're looking at a consensus
short idea that is old, that is stale,
that is not an original idea.
So it's a lazy default short in the
market.
So this could be a situation, for example,
like a phase four or phase five scenario.
But it could also be a phase one scenario.
So this is actually a good thing for your
longs.
But obviously, it's a bad thing for any
shorts.
So the question here is always, what is a
dangerous short interest percentage level
for short ideas?
Well, with this one, there is no right
answer.
I've been involved in situations where on
the professional side, for example, I've
seen situations where there's been 60, 70,
80% short interest in a stock.
And things are going really bad for the
company and it's actually really justified
because they can go bankrupt.
And I've seen situations where one hedge
fund has been 35, 40% of the entire shares
in issue short the stock and the stock
goes to zero.
So with the percentage short interest
itself for short ideas, there is no right
answer here as to a level that is
dangerous.
It always has to be taken in the context
of what's actually happening with the
stock.
In that situation, for example, where one
hedge fund is short 35, 40% of all the
shares in issue and the total short
interest is 70, 80% of all shares in
issue.
In that situation, the stock is cratering
and it's generally in situations like that
trading its market cap every day or even
more than the value of its market cap
every day.
So there's a lot of liquidity in the stock
as it's traveling towards zero.
So the days to cover ratio in a situation
like that might be surprisingly low.
So with percentage short interest, you
can't look at it and say just because it's
15% or 25% or 45% or 65% that it's high.
And there's a liquidity issue.
The liquidity issue is captured by the
days to cover ratio.
With the short interest percentage, that
is more of a sentiment issue.
It gives you a gauge on how hated the
stock is by the market, how bearish the
market is.
The days to cover ratio tells you if
there's a liquidity issue with the shorts.
So obvious question, what is a dangerous
days to cover ratio for shorts?
Well, as a liquidity measure for S&P 500
stocks.
So fairly big stocks, large cap and mega
cap stocks above 15 days starts to become
marginal.
And once you start getting into the 20 day
area, it starts to get dangerous and above
30 days, it officially is dangerous.
So the way you've got to think about it is
this.
When you look at the formula of the days
to cover ratio, which is the amount of
shares sold short over the average daily
volume of the stock for the last 30 days.
This formula is assuming that if everybody
in the market went into the market to buy
their shorts back, that they're going to
be 100% of the volume on an average day,
which obviously technically can't be the
case.
A more likely scenario is that they're
going to be 20, 25, 30, 33% of the volume,
something like this.
So imagine if you see a days to cover
ratio of 20 days in a stock, what does
that really mean?
Well, that 20 days assumes that if all the
shorts went into the market to buy all of
their stock back to cover their shorts,
that it would take them 20 days based on
the average daily volume of the last 30
days.
But in reality, that can't happen.
They can't be 100% of the volume.
So let's assume that they went into the
market and they were 25% of the day's
volume.
That means it would take them 80 trading
days for all the shorts to cover their
positions.
So you have to think of the short interest
percentage as a sentiment indicator and
the days to cover ratio as a liquidity
measure.
And think of the days to cover ratio in
terms of order flow.
So in terms of unwinds, so unwinding as a
percentage of the volume.
So this is why, for example, in periods
like phase four and phase five of our
short wave template, we try to avoid being
the hero and shorting stocks based on past
information,
thinking that fundamentals are just going
to continually get worse and the stock is
going to zero.
We don't need to be the heroes in shorting
stocks to zero.
We can find and be happy with shorting
stocks in phase two and phase three.
Because often what you will find with
stocks in phase four and phase five is
that there's a lot of consensus short
positioning and technically the market can
get itself in a bit of a mess or a big
mess by getting short.
Too many shares as a percentage of the
amount of shares in issue and relative to
the average daily volume of the stock.
So when the company starts making noises,
some positive noises around a possible
turnaround story, we can get big short
squeezes in the stock where everyone has
to go in and buy the stock all at the same
time to cover their shorts.
But they cut because there's no liquidity
in the stock for the amount of shares that
have been sold short in the market from
the consensus positioning.
But in the year 2021, we saw some examples
of this play themselves out in the market
where the victims of the short interest
were actually on the professional side of
the industry.
So I'm sure you've all heard of the
GameStop GME fiasco.
Here, there's a screenshot that we took in
April 2021 where we're just capturing in
this screenshot the amount of shares
outstanding and the float of the company.
We can also see that the share price is
currently $186.95.
The short interest percentage of the float
is 10.2 million shares, which makes 18.84%
of the float.
And we also have a days to cover ratio of
roughly one third of a day to cover that
short.
So roughly back of the envelope, the
amount of shares that were changing hands
each day must have been around 30 million
shares.
But what we can also get and what is
interesting is to look at the history of
the short interest level, the amount of
shares that have been sold short in the
market, the history of that.
And we can see back in December 2020,
going back for a period of at least four
or five months where we can see that the
total level of shares that were sold short
in the market is around 70 million shares.
Which is equivalent, which is equivalent,
as we know from the screenshot taken on
the previous screen, which is equivalent
to the total amount of shares in issue,
the amount of shares outstanding.
So it's equivalent to the entire market
cap of the company.
Now, GameStop GME as a stock was for a
long time on a long, slow decline as a
stock, as a company, fundamentally, and
had gone well beyond its X growth phase
and was in the phase five scenario.
So what we would characterize as the phase
five scenario.
And they were in the phase five scenario
for a very long time.
As in, it was a potential turnaround or
value trap for an extremely long time.
And the turnaround just never happened
over and over and over again.
And some smart ass in the professional
training world on the hedge fund side
decided that this stock stays were over.
It's going to zero.
And he wanted to be the hero.
And he forgot about all his basic
principles of shorting and decided to end
up shorting a significant percentage of
the amount of shares in issue.
And as the stock started to creep up, he
just got shorter and shorter and shorter,
convinced that the stock was going to
zero.
The company was bankrupt.
It was never going to turn around.
And he was trying to be the hero.
Well, guess what happened to that guy?
Here's the stock.
In January 2021, some retail traders in
the fourth quarter of 2020 got onto this
and decided that GME GameStop presented
value with some potential upside.
And that there was a crowded short in the
market that could be exploited.
And they went and bought some stock and
then distributed the trade idea on public
forums.
And then lots of retail traders came in to
buy stock and call options.
And the stock started rallying
aggressively in the second week of January
2021.
And just a few weeks later, the stock had
gone from essentially $10, $20 a share
above $400 a share.
So the hedge fund that was short, the
majority of the shares outstanding in the
market got absolutely killed.
And a lot of retail traders made good
money on that trade.
So in October 2020, GameStop was trading
below $10 a share.
And at $10 a share, their market cap was
around $700 million.
The short interest in the stock from April
2020 to August 2020 was roughly between
$50 million to $60 million shares sold
short of the $70 million shares
outstanding.
And as we can see from the previous chart
that we looked at, short interest
continued to rise as the stock rose to $70
million shares.
So the hedge funds, and there was one main
hedge fund that was the majority of the
short.
So the hedge funds that were short, they
were essentially short the equivalent of
the entire market cap of the company.
So all the shares in issue.
Now being short $50 to $60 million of the
$70 million shares outstanding is totally
irresponsible to begin with.
But even worse, they were getting shorter
and shorter as the stock rose to try and
defend the short and sit on the stock so
it wouldn't rally and the rally wouldn't
kill them.
So what lessons can we take from this?
Well, shorting stocks in a hole and going
for the hero trade is not something we
want to be involved in ever.
No matter how convinced you are, we should
be staying away from these phase four and
phase five situations.
We don't need to expose ourselves to the
hero to zero trade.
hero trade.
We can be quite happy to be playing the
phase two and phase three moves over a
shorter time horizon.
And this is again why we have a market cap
limit on shorts, because essentially a
market cap limit is also a liquidity
limit.
So when you're generating short ideas and
you see X growth companies that are
fundamentally a short, so you have the
earnings growth profiles, you've done
further work, and you believe the stock is
going to go lower and it's a phase two and
phase three situation.
And if it's a green light and it's
acceptable, of course, you can go ahead
and short the stock if it's genuinely X
growth and in the phase two and phase
three scenarios.
However, if you see fundamentals in the
earnings growth that are questionable, you
pull up the stock and it's down a lot
already.
It seems to be in the phase four period.
Management are making noises about a
turnaround and a new operating plan, a new
management operating plan.
You check the short interest percentage
and it's very high.
You check the days to cover and it's above
15, perhaps above 20, even worse above 30.
You check the short interest rate.
This is an issue.
These are the types of short ideas that we
want to stay away from.
Why?
Because we will end up like this donut at
Melvin Capital.
Gabe Plotkin, who was the guy behind the
GME short.
Yes, they were down 49% on their entire
fund in the first quarter of 2021, which
is an irrecoverable position, even for a
professional hedge fund manager.
That is an absolute disaster.
For a retail trader, 49% in a quarter loss
as well is a disaster.
So these are the situations that we need
to stay away from.
Stay away from the scenarios that are
phase four and phase five.
Try not to get into bad habits of trying
to short stocks in a hole and being the
hero thinking that you've got an edge over
the market and that a stock that's already
down 80% is going to deteriorate further
and go to zero.
And you're the hero calling it and you're
going to be the guy that makes all the
money.
Make sure you stay away from those
situations.
Also, make sure that you stay away from
bad habits of shorting stocks too early in
phase one.
Try to tend towards good behaviors of
shorting stocks in phase two, taking
advantage of a phase two move and taking
advantage of a phase three move and then
move on to the next one.
So we always need to use short interest
percentage and the days to cover ratio as
a head check on our fundamental work to
figure out what the technical situation is
in the market before even thinking about
initiating a position.
Now, does this mean that we should use
short interest percentage and days to
cover as a way to find long ideas and
short ideas?
So for example, you rank short interest
percentage and days to cover numbers via
the website shortsqueeze.com and you just
simply go long, high short interest names
and short, low short interest names.
Well, no, of course not.
This is not how we generate trade ideas.
This is just one tiny part of the overall
process that may allow you to avoid or
swerve traps and or to confirm that your
potential idea is not consensus.
So always, always, always make sure of the
short interest percentage and the days to
cover ratio when you've generated what you
believe is a fundamentally driven short
idea.
You need to check the technical situation
in the market with short interest
percentage and days to cover.
Now, something else that you need to check
as a technical situation as well is
whether a company is paying a dividend or
not.
This becomes quite important even in the
20 to 60 day time horizon.
So if a company is paying a dividend
within that time horizon, it becomes quite
important as a technical situation to
consider.
So the questions you need to ask yourself
are, is a company actually paying a
dividend or not?
If they are, how much is the dividend in
terms of cents per share and also as a
percentage yield?
And also, what is the likelihood that the
company is going to cut their dividend?
Now, the reason why this is important is
because when you are short a dividend
paying stock, you are actually what is
termed short the dividend.
You are a borrower of stock from a stock
owner and you will owe them the dividend.
Now, in reality, in your trading account,
you won't actually have to physically take
any action at all.
The broker should do everything for you on
your behalf.
So running through an example, let's say
we have a $100 stock that pays a dividend
of $1 per quarter.
So they're paying $4 over the year, $4 in
total, 4% dividend yield.
Now, let's say you've identified this
stock as a potential fundamental short.
So after all your hard work of identifying
the stock as a short, you decide that
you're going to short a hundred shares of
this $100 stock.
So your position is going to be $10,000
notional or gross exposure.
Now, let's say the stock goes down $10 to
$90 a share before the next ex-dividend
date.
So this is great.
This is a good situation because you're
short at $100.
Congratulations.
You're making money.
Your position is now 100 shares short at
$100, showing a profit of $1,000.
And your mark-to-market gross exposure is
100 shares at $90.
So $9,000 notional gross exposure that's
marked to market.
Now, on the next quarterly ex-dividend
day, you open your brokerage platform and
the stock has gone what we call
ex-dividend by the $1 dividend per share.
And your average price that you are short,
originally from $100, has now gone to $99
in the trading platform, in your trading
account.
And the stock opens $1 lower that day at
$89.
So in the new situation, what's your
position?
What's your profit or loss?
What is your actual gross exposure?
Well, your position is still short 100
shares, but now you have an average price
of being short at $99.
So with the stock at $89, you're still up
$10 on 100 shares short.
So your P&L is still up $1,000.
But your gross exposure is now 100 shares
mark-to-market at $89.
So $8,900.
So this is because the stock has now gone
ex-dividend by $1.
So they've paid out a quarterly dividend
of the $1 per share.
And this money leaves the company balance
sheet.
On the ex-dividend date, the stock adjusts
lower by $1 to reflect the value of the
dividend that's been paid out to the stock
owners, the shareholders.
So for yourself who is short as a person
or entity that has a short position, you
do not own the stock.
And therefore, you don't receive the
dividend.
So the $1 per share.
So your average price adjusts to reflect
the fact that you didn't receive it.
On the long side, the owner of the stock
that you owe the dividend to receives the
$1 per share dividend at some point in the
future on the dividend payable or
settlement date.
And the owner of the stock has their
average price adjusted down also by $1.
However, they actually receive the $1
payment into their trading account at the
settlement date.
As the short seller, you don't receive any
payment.
So for the stock owner, the trade is
simply a wash.
There's a $1 stock adjustment and $1
average price adjustment.
For a person or entity who is short, it's
just an average price adjustment.
So let's make this a little bit more
clear.
Imagine if you kept the short position on
for a decade, for 10 years, what would
actually happen?
Well, for the company, there would be $41
dividend payments made to shareholders in
that period because it's a quarterly $1
dividend.
So let's say the stock over the 10 years
goes from $100 to $200 in terms of
appreciation.
Well, the owner of the shares receives $40
in dividends realized and has made $100
unrealized in terms of capital gain on the
stock's appreciation.
So the owner's new average price, because
they're receiving all of these 40
dividends, these $41 dividends, the
owner's new average price is $60.
So on an initial investment of 100 shares
at $100, so the $10,000 notional, they've
made a profit of $140 per share with 100
shares.
So it's $14,000 profit on top of the
$10,000 initial investment.
The short seller of 100 shares over the
same time period loses $40 in value of
dividend value because they didn't receive
the dividend as a realized payment.
So the short seller's new average price is
also $60 but they didn't receive any
dividends.
So they have an unrealized loss of $140
per share or $40,000 on the initial short
of the notional $10,000.
Now, on the actual ex-dividend date that a
stock goes ex-dividend, typically, but not
all the time, stocks will go higher than
their ex-dividend adjustment price.
And this is mainly because a lot of
shareholders elect to automatically
reinvest the dividend back into the stock.
So from the example that we've been going
through, the owner that received the $100
dividend when the stock was at $89 at the
ex-dividend adjustment price,
they may have elected to automatically buy
one share at $89.
Now, if all the owners of the stock do
this, then the stock will likely not go
down on the ex-dividend date and will be
up, potentially when even buyers break
limit.
So we term this by saying the stock went
ex-dividend.
Well, so on the ex-dividend date, the
stock actually went up above the
ex-dividend adjustment price.
If the stock closes lower than the
adjustment price of $89, we term this as
the stock went ex-dividend badly.
So a stock can go ex-dividend well or
badly for multiple other reasons.
There are many variables at play here.
So for example, when the US stock market
is closed, if a company is or a stock is
going ex-dividend the following day and
overnight,
for example, overseas markets, the wider
stock markets may have just been up really
big overnight.
And the stock could just open up the next
day in the US at $92 with a dividend
adjustment price of $89.
So it could be up $3 on the ex-dividend
day for that reason.
It doesn't really matter what the reason
is.
If the stock closes on the ex-dividend day
above $89, so our ex-dividend adjustment
price, the stock still went ex-dividend
well.
Below $89, the stock simply went
ex-dividend badly.
So does this mean as a short seller that
you should always avoid being short
dividend paying stocks?
Well, no, of course not.
If the business operation of the company
is cratering, then the dividend is likely
to get cut and could be cut entirely.
So the stock in anticipation of that could
just get absolutely hammered and the
dividend just doesn't even matter.
So if you're looking to short a dividend
paying stock, then you have to have a good
or high level of conviction that the
dividend is actually going to get cut.
So as with short interest percentage and
with the days to cover ratio, we have to
have a head check also for the technical
situation in the market with the company's
dividend if they're paying a dividend at
all.
And we need to ask ourselves the pretty
serious questions that are actually very
simple and straightforward to answer.
Firstly, is the company paying a dividend?
Secondly, how much?
And third, what is the likelihood that the
company is going to cut the dividend?
So we must have this process in place as a
head check additional to short interest
and days to cover to make sure we're happy
being short a stock that actually pays a
dividend.
And the amount of the dividend and the
likelihood so we're actually happy that
we're doing it.
So have your fundamentally driven short
trade idea in place.
Check the short interest percentage.
Check the days to cover ratio.
Check the dividend situation.
Are they paying a dividend?
How much and what's the likelihood that
they're going to cut the dividend based on
my analysis of the business operation?
If all of those are in place and you're
happy with the situation, you're happy
with the fundamentals and happy with the
short interest, days to cover and dividend
situation, then your short trade idea
probably has a green light.
But remember, we still have a lot more
work to do in the trade idea generation
process for shorts and as well as longs.
We don't just get our trade ideas by
ranking for earnings growth and then go
long and short stocks.
But we obviously have to do a lot more
work on the companies to see what's behind
earnings growth, valuation, etc.
Remember when we're looking at the
earnings growth profiles in a sector like
we have done and characterized the
earnings growth profiles in this video
from a short perspective through a short
lens.
This is an identification process.
We continue to do more work once we have
identified what we believe to be negative
outliers in a particular sector and our
further work will determine whether we
believe our trade idea is actually a green
light and is actually a short.
So let's summarize everything here for
short idea processing.
So for our quant processes on identifying
potential short ideas, we outlined the
earnings growth profiles that we look for.
Now, sequentially negative earnings growth
is ideal in quotes on paper.
However, in a GDP growth environment, it
is much harder to find than if we were in
a GDP slowdown or an expected GDP
contraction environment.
In addition to that, we also have to
consider that if EPS growth expectations
have already been set in the market at
sequentially negative as a profile,
it is very likely that the stock has
already moved quite a bit lower.
So what we want to be doing as traders is
targeting the phase two and phase three
scenarios on the journey of a stock
falling.
We will most probably find ourselves going
for the next best thing after sequentially
negative earnings growth profiles in our
list.
So cases number two, three, four and five
as long as we are in what we characterized
as a phase two or phase three scenario of
stock price decline on its journey on the
way down.
We also have to add market cap filters on
our shorts to avoid making the rookie
errors of, for example, like shorting
stocks in a hole and going for the zero to
hero trade.
Additionally, we have to overlay our
fundamental work with technical factors in
our process in the quantum phase, for
example, checking the short interest days
to cover ratio and the dividend situation.
Most importantly, out of the technical
factors, we want to make sure that we are
not exposing ourselves to high levels of
short interest.
So high levels of short interest and high
days to cover, which basically is a
warning sign that we could be entering or
getting sucked into consensus market
positioning.
So high levels of short interest that
indicate extreme bearish sentiment that's
already occurring in the market.
And also on top of that, a very high days
to cover ratio, which means there could be
a liquidity issue and we could get a short
squeeze in the stock and get caught out.
At the end of the day, we are traders, not
investors.
Catching the phase two and phase three
scenario in an X growth stock is what we
are looking to achieve with our short
ideas.
We are seeking to predict and participate
in a fundamental shift lower in
expectations of the business operation.
To achieve earnings, we want to achieve
earnings EPS, earnings growth and even
revenue growth as well.
And as always, just like with long ideas,
we want to be catching the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
And with shorts, what we want to be
focusing on is attempting to catch the
sharp moves down in the stock during those
phase two and phase three periods.
So that about wraps it up for this video
with short idea processing in the quant
phase.
I don't think we need a summary again by
going back to the desk for this one.
Let's go right in to the next video where
we're going to be looking at turnaround
stories and value traps.